The late seventeenth century had its own peculiar kind of heresy one that didn't burn at the stake,
but festered in the soul. Quietism, they called it. A doctrine so radical it dared to suggest
that salvation lay not in prayer or penance, but in doing nothing at all. Not the passive
resignation of a martyr, but the deliberate erasure of self. Imagine it. A life so stripped
of motion, of choice, of even the faintest whisper of desire, that you became less a person than a
shadow cast by one. And here's the thing it worked. We call it monotony, as art. Because misery,
like fine wine, benefits from aging. But not just any aging. The kind that requires no effort,
no risk, no deviation from the script, a high-variance life travel, new flavors, the occasional
jolt of the unexpected, is a life that thrives on chaos. It's anti-fragile, as they say in the trade,
but you, you want the opposite. You want the slow, surgical removal of all possibility.
You want a world so perfectly gray that even your own existence becomes a background hum,
something you barely register anymore. The brain you see is a traitor. It's wired to ignore what
doesn't change. That's why you stop noticing the clutter on your desk. Why the hum of your computer
fades into silence. Why after a while, even the air you breathe stops feeling like air at all.
It's called habituation the brain's way of conserving energy by checking out entirely. And if you
engineer your life just right, you can habituate to everything. Start with the uniform of indifference.
Breakfast, lunch, same thing, every day. No variations. No surprises. Your body stops craving.
Your mind stops wandering. Then the clothes. The same style. The same colors. The same texture
against your skin. No new sensations. No accidental pleasures. You're not dressing anymore. You're
wearing the cage. Next, the routine fortress. 15-minute increments mapped out in advance. No detours.
No spontaneous walks. No what-if moments. Always the same path to work. Always the same pace. And soon,
your brain switches off entirely. The commute isn't a journey anymore. It's a dead hour, stretched thin
across the day. A masterclass in the art of being absent. Then comes the aesthetics of beige. Your home
isn't a place to live. It's a sensory neutral zone. No vibrant colors. No interesting textures.
No art that might dare to provoke a thought. Just walls that don't demand attention. Floors that
don't whisper. A space so bland that your eyes have nowhere to land. Your mind nowhere to wander.
And if, God forbid, something new slips in. A serendipitous encounter. A moment of unexpected
joy. You don't indulge it. You don't let it linger. You categorize it immediately as a distraction.
A threat. And you return, swiftly, to the routine. Because every new thing is a crack in the monotony.
Every deviation is a betrayal of the gray. The goal? Total habituation. A life so transparent you
forget you're alive at all. You exist, but you don't feel it. You're a ghost in your own story.
And that, my friend, is the ultimate aesthetic of misery. The ability to stare into a world of
infinite possibility and see nothing but a single, flat, unchanging shade of gray.
They wrote about it in the residence log back in March. Indoor air stagnation. The subject refused
to open the windows. Kept the temperature locked in place. Even the air they breathed became part of
the performance. Because what's a breath, really? Just another sensation to habituate. Another thing
to stop noticing. And then there's the prisoner's wisdom. The prisoner who knows the exact number of
bars in his cell is the only one who is truly home. Count the bars. How poetic. How efficient.
Because in the end, misery isn't about suffering. It's about control. The control of never having to
choose. Never having to wonder. Never having to feel anything at all. Just the slow, steady erosion of
self, until all that's left is the quiet hum of a life well spent in gray.